EDITION OF HANTY.
I’M IN TONIGHT FOR SEAN.
YESTERDAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE
A SURPRISE VISIT TO THE AL-ASSAD
AIR BASE IN IRAQ WHERE HE
VISITED THE BRAVE MEN AND WHIP
SERVING ABROAD DURING CHRISTMAS.
BACK AT HOME THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA TRASHED THE PRESIDENT OVER
HIS VISIT WITH OUR TROOPS.
WATCH THIS.
>> IN RETROSPECT, I GIVE HIM
CREDIT FOR GOING TO IRAQ, BUT
HIS PERFORMANCE THERE WAS
SHAMEFUL.
>> THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO HAVE
CONFUSED THIS TROOP VISIT WITH A
CAMPAIGN RALLY.
>> IT WAS A POLITICAL RALLY IN
FRONT OF TROOPS IN IRAQ.
>> THEY TREAT THE TROOPS LIKE
PROPS, IT CONVERTS THE TROOPS
INTO A PARTISAN PLAY THING.
>> IT’S THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS AND THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO ARE SUPPORTING
OUR ARMED FORCES.
THEY DON’T BELONG TO HIM.
>> HE’S THE GRINCH.
I’M BEING HONEST.
>> HE STOLE CHRISTMAS.
>> IT WAS SO NEGATIVE AND SO,
YOU WANT POSITIVITY WHEN IT
COMES TO CHRISTMAS.
IT IS PERPLEXING.
WHY WOULD HE VISIT THE TROOPS
AND DO THAT?
>> JASON: THE ALL TOO
PREDICTABLE ATTACKS CONTINUED ON
CNN, WHERE PUNDITS CRITICIZED
TRUMP FOR AUTOGRAPHS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> REPORTERS TRAVELING SAID THE
TROOPS BROUGHT THE HATS WITH
THEM, INCLUDING ONE HAT THAT
SAID TRUMP 2020.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE IF THAT
PROVES TO BE THE CASE.
THEM.
THE QUESTION IS, IF THEY BROUGHT
THEM OR IF THE PRESIDENT BROUGHT
WHAT COMMANDER ALLOWED THAT TO
HAPPEN?
THIS IS VERY MUCH AGAINST
MILITARY POLICY AND REGULATION.
TROOPS ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
INVOLVED IN POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES.
THE U.S. MILITARY IS NOT A
POLITICAL FORCE.
AND THERE’S NO QUESTION THE
SAYING TRUMP 2020 AND MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, THOSE ARE
POLITICAL SLOGANS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE NOT GOVERNMENTAL
SAYINGS.
TO SAY THE LEAST.
>> JASON: OF COURSE, YOU DIDN’T
HEAR THOUGH ATTACKS UNDER OBAMA.
HEAR THOUGH ATTACKS UNDER OBAMA.IN 2008 WHEN HE WAS RUNNING FOR
IN 2008 WHEN HE WAS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, THEN CANDIDATE OBAMA
PRESIDENT, THEN CANDIDATE OBAMA
SIGNED MEMORABILIA AND RALLIED
THE TROOPS DURING AN EVENT AT A
MILITARY BASE IN KUWAIT.
FOUR YEARS LATER AS PRESIDENT
RUNNING FOR RE-ELECTION HE TOOK
PICTURES AT A BASE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
COURSE HE DID.
BUT NOW THAT IT’S TRUMP AND HE’S
THE PRESIDENT, THIS IS NO LONGER
ALLOWED?
PRIME EXAMPLE OF BLATANT MEDIA
BIAS.
JOINING US NOW IS FOX NEWS
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGIST
SEBASTIEN GORGA, MORGAN ORTEGAS
AND RNC NATIONAL SPOKESMAN
KAILEE MCANENNY.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
KAILEE.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD IS SO
BLATANT HERE.
BUT DO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, DO
THEY SEE THROUGH THIS?
WHAT SHOULD THEY READ FROM THESE
MEDIA REPORTS?
>> JASON, THERE’S NO DOUBT THAT
THIS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THROUGH
HERE IS THE BEAUTY OF ALL OF
THIS, IF THERE IS ANY SILVER
LINING.
THE MEDIA HAS ELIMINATED THE
NEED OF THE PRESIDENT TO CALL
THEM OUT, TO EXPOSE THEIR BIAS.
THEY’VE BECOME SO BIAS, SO
RIDICULOUS, SO OUTRAGEOUS.
LITERALLY WRITING A HEADLINE,
WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN THE
AIR TO VISIT THE TROOPS THAT HE
AIR TO VISIT THE TROOPS THAT HE IS BECOMING THE FIRST PRESIDENT
IS BECOMING THE FIRST PRESIDENT
SINCE 2002 TO NOT VISIT THE
TROOPS.
THEY HAVE BECOME A PARITY OF
THAT IS FAKE NEWS AT ITS FINEST.
THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE EXPOSING THEMSELVES.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE IN TUNE
WITH IT.
THEY’RE DOING THEMSELVES A
DISSERVICE BY GOING TO NEGATIVE
BUT AN IT’S SO BLATANT AND
OBVIOUS TO THE CASUAL OBSERVER.
>> JASON: YOU’RE VERY CLOSE TO
THE PRESIDENT.
WHY DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY MADE THIS TRIP?
IT WASN’T TO SIGN AUTOGRAPHS AND
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HATS.
>> I KNOW WHY HE MADE IT, JASON.
I CALLED THE WHITE HOUSE.
I SPOKE WITH THE WHITE HOUSE ON
CHRISTMAS EVE.
HE DID THIS BECAUSE THIS WAS
IMPORTANT TO HIM AND IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR MELANIA.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME A FIRST
LADY HAS VISITED AN ACTIVE WAR
ZONE SINCE 1969.
THE FACT THAT CNN AND THE REST
OF THE FAKE NEWS INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX IS ATTACKING THOSE THAT
WEAR THE UNIFORM OF THE
REPUBLIC, THAT ARE SERVING IN A
WAR ZONE, IT’S AN UTTER DISGRACE
AND OUTRAGE.
I WORKED FOR THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT FOR MORE THAN FIVE
YEARS.
I WAS SUBJECT TO THE RULES THAT
REQUIRE YOU TO REMAIN
POLITICALLY NEUTRAL AS A
CIVILIAN.
I HAVE READ THE REGULATIONS THAT
APPLY TO THOSE IN UNIFORM.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO BE
INVOLVED IN POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNING, JASON.
YOU KNOW THAT AS WELL AS I DO.
THE IDEA THAT YOU ARE ASKING
YOUR COMMANDER IN CHIEF FOR HIS
AUTOGRAPH ON A HAT IS NOT A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN ACTION.
ALL WE NEED TO KNOW RIGHT NOW
IS, IF YOU LOVE THIS COUNTRY
LIKE THE PRESIDENT DOES, IF YOU
LOVE THIS COUNTRY LIKE OUR
SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN, THEN CNN
AND THE REST OF THAT CREW WILL
HATE YOU.
IT IS REALLY THAT SIMPLE.
JASON: I THOUGHT THE REPORTING
WAS SHAMEFUL.
JOINING ME HERE IN NEW YORK IN
STUDIO IS MORGAN ORTEGAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
PEOPLE DON’T KNOW THIS, BUT YOU
SERVED OUR COUNTRY IN SAUDI
ARABIA AND IRAQ.
WE THANK YOU FOR THAT SERVICE.
THE PRESIDENT COMES OVER.
AN UNANNOUNCED TRIP.
THE PEOPLE THERE, THEY DON’T
KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT’S
COMING.
THEY MAY HAVE GOTTEN A COUPLE
HOURS NOTICE, IF THAT.
WHEN YOU SERVE OVERSEAS, RIGHT,
YOU TAKE WHAT’S PRECIOUS AND
DEAR TO YOU, WHICH YOU CARE
ABOUT, AND YOUR SPACE IS VERY
LIMITED.
SO THE FACT THESE PEOPLE HAD
THIS ON HAND, KNOWING MAYBE WITH
AN HOUR’S NOTICE THAT THE
PRESIDENT’S COMING, SAYS
SOMETHING ABOUT THE INTENTION OF
WHERE THESE PEOPLE BELIEVE.
HE GOT A ROUSING, ROUSING
APPLAUSE WHEN HE WALKED INTO
THAT RAORPBL DIDN’T HE?
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT’S
INTERESTING?
WHEN BARACK OBAMA, WHEN GEORGE
W. BUSH, OTHER PRESIDENTS,
REGARDLESS OF PARTY, GO TO THE
REGION WHERE THE TROOPS ARE
SERVING, THEY GET ROUNDS OF
APPLAUSE.
WHY IS THAT?
THESE MEMBERS SERVE AT THE
PLEASURE OF THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
THEY’RE AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS ON CHRISTMAS.
IT’S ENERGIZING TO SEE YOUR
PRESIDENT.
A TRIP LIKE THAT, WHEN I WAS
WITH THE U.S. EMBASSY IN RIYADH,
IF WE HAD A CABINET OFFICIAL OR
HIGH LEVEL OFFICIAL COMING IN,
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN PLANNED
WEEKS IN ADVANCE TORQUE THE
CRITICISM THAT IT HAD SOMETHING
TO DO WITH SYRIA OR THE
SHUTDOWN, IT’S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
TO PLAN SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN DONE AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS MANY WEEKS IN
ADVANCE.
I THINK THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE THINGS, OFTEN THERE’S
TIMES WHERE WE LOOK AT SOMETHING
THAT THE PRESIDENT DID AND YOU
SEE A LOT OF STUFF IN THE MEDIA
I THINK IT’S BEING OVERBLOWN.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE CASES, I’M
IN THE RESERVES.
I DO NOT SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
MILITARY.
I SERVE WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS, DOWN THE
MIDDLE.
WE DON’T BRING OUR PARTISAN
AFFILIATION INTO THE UNIFORM.
BUT WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS THERE,
REGARDLESS OF PARTY, YOU’RE
HAPPY TO SEE YOUR PRESIDENT.
TO SEE THESE REPORTERS, I GOT TO
SAY, HOW ALL THIS HAPPENED,
THERE WAS A REPORTER WHO TOOK
PICTURES OF PEOPLE’S FACES AND
NAME PLATES WHICH, BY THE WAY,
IS NOT THE BEST IDEA TO BEGIN
WITH AND MADE SURE THEY WERE
DOCUMENTED ON TWITTER WITH THESE
HATS AND THE TRUMP BANNER FOR
THEM OUT.
THE EXPLICIT PURPOSE OF CALLING
THAT REPORTER, I WOULDN’T LET
THAT PERSON BACK IN THE WHITE
HOUSE PRESS CORPS.
>> JASON: IS THERE ANYTHING THE
PRESIDENT CAN DO THAT WOULD BE
RIGHT?
IT DOESN’T SEEM TO MATTER WHAT
THIS PRESIDENT DOES.
THEY ALWAYS SEEM TO FIND FAULT
IN IT.
EVEN VISITING THE TROOPS AT
CHRISTMASTIME.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE DOES WHAT IS RIGHT AND YET IS
STILL CALLED OUT FOR IT WITH
BLATANT BIAS AND WITH
EDITORIALIZING, WITH FAKE NEWS
STORIES.
I WATCHED THE ENTIRETY OF HIS 25
MINUTE SPEECH.
IT WAS A VERY BEAUTIFUL SPEECH.
FOR THOSE WHO DIDN’T SEE IT AIR
LIVE, GO WATCH IT.
HE SITS THERE AND THANKS THE
TROOPS.
HE SAYS THANK YOU FOR WINNING
BACK 20,000 SQUARE MILES OF
TERRITORY FROM ISIS.
THANK YOU FOR LIBERATING 3
MILLION CITIZENS.
THANK YOU FOR SACRIFICING AND
BEING AWAY FROM YOUR FAMILIAR
LIST.
HE SAID AND DID EVERYTHING
RIGHT.
THAT’S JUST IT.
HE CAN DO EVERYTHING RIGHT.
THE MEDIA, HOWEVER, AS FOUND BY
A HARVARD STUDY, IS 90%
NEGATIVE.
THEY WILL REMAIN NEGATIVE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE HAVE
AN ELECTION IN 2020.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL REWARD
HIM FOR DOING WHAT IS RIGHT
DESPITE THE MEDIA ONSLAUGHT,
DESPITE THE ONSLAUGHT HE ENDURES
EVERY DAY.
>> JASON: I THOUGHT HAVING THE
FIRST LADY MAKE THAT TRIP WAS
ALL A VERY NICE TOUCH.
SEBASTIEN, YOU, AGAIN, WITH THE
TROOPS, THE MESSAGE THAT IT
SENDS NOT ONLY TO THE PEOPLE
THERE IN IRAQ THAT ARE SERVING,
BUT OVERSEAS IN JAPAN AND ACROSS
THE WORLD.
THE MESSAGE HAS GOT TO BE A
RESOUNDING DONALD TRUMP HAS YOUR
BACK.
>> YOU TOOK THE WORDS OUT OF MY
MOUTH.
THAT WAS THE NEXT THING I WAS
GOING TO SAY.
I’D LIKE TO ENCOURAGE ALL THE
VIEWERS TO GO BACK TO MY TWITTER
FEED, LOOK AT SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS.
LOOK AT THE PHOTOGRAPHS FROM
IRAQ.
LOOK AT THE FACES OF THOSE
SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN.
LOOK AT THE PHOTOGRAPHS FROM
GERMANY.
THEY ARE SO OVERJOYED THAT ON
CHRISTMAS DAY DONALD TRUMP AND
MELANIA TRUMP DON’T SPEND THEIR
PRECIOUS TIME TOGETHER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE OR AT MAR LAGO.
THEY FLY TO THE MIDDLE EAST.
THEY FLY TO THE BASE.
THEY KNOW THAT ONE TRIP TELLS
THEM EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT HOW MUCH THIS
COMMANDER IN CHIEF HAS THEIR
BACK.
>> JASON: I HAVE GOT JUST A FEW
SECOND.
I WANT TO GIVE MORGAN THE LAST
WORD HERE.
THE ONLY THING THAT I HAVE SEEN
BARACK OBAMA -- THE ONLY THING
HE WAS WILLING TO CUT WAS HIS
DEFENSE BUDGET.
BUT THIS PRESIDENT HAS PROPPED
THAT UP BY TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
>> WHAT’S ALSO NOT BEING TALKED
ABOUT, ON THAT TRIP THE
PRESIDENT WAS MEETING WITH HIS
SENIOR MILITARY COMMANDERS ON
THE GROUND.
THE TEAM HAS ALREADY STARTED TO
SHOW THAT THEY’RE THINKING ABOUT
SHOW THAT THEY’RE THINKING ABOUTPERHAPS A NEW STRATEGY FOR SYRIA
PERHAPS A NEW STRATEGY FOR SYRIAAS IT RELATES TO KEEPING TROOPS
AS IT RELATES TO KEEPING TROOPS
THERE.
THE PRESIDENT INKATED HE’S GOING
TO KEEP TROOPS IN IRAQ.
FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME, THIS WAS A
FANTASTIC TRIP.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL.
THE PRESIDENT GOT TO SEE ALL OF
THE STUFF THAT IS DELIBERATED IN
HE GOT TO SEE IT.
IT MIGHT HAVE EVEN NOT
NECESSARILY CHANGED HIS MIND,
BUT HELPED HIM SORT OF
STRENGTHEN HIS STRATEGY AS IT
RELATES TO SYRIA AND IRAQ.
THAT’S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
NO ONE’S TALKING ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THEY JUST WANT TO
CRITICIZE HIM FOR SIGNING A HAT.
>> JASON: I HOPE THE PRESIDENT
CONTINUES TO DO THIS.
IT MEANS THE WORLD TO THEM.
TO DO IT CHRISTMASTIME.
AND SHAME ON THE MEDIA FOR
REPORTING IT.